Du behöver inte vara schysst i detta.
Alltså, så som det ska vara får du säga.
Så som det är är att marknadsförare har bäst förståelse för de har bäst förståelse för kunderna.
Så det är de som ska bestämma allt för hela ditt bolag.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Pontus Löfven från Republiken hit till podden.
Tjena Pontus.
Tjena, tjena.
Innan man börjar avsnittet får man nästan ta en paus och gå in och söka på er.
Man får söka på Republiken och så får man gå in på er hemsida bara för att få en notering.
Så om ni har möjlighet så gör det.
Ni är ju en marknadsföringsbyrå men jag noterade er för att ni har en lite weird approach.
Eller ni sticker ut lite er att det är formspråk.
Ni kniklar ut det till någon sorts centaurion, så säger man.
Ni är det gamla Romariket.
Ja exakt.
Vad är grejen där?
Kan vi fastna i det först?
Ja, grejen är att det finns alldeles för många marknadsföringsbyråer.
Det finns alldeles för många byråer som låter likadant.
Så istället får vi heta Grow Digital.
Och har en massa häftiga flåsklor på vår site, så gör vi något annorlunda.
Så vi klär oss i tåga, vi pratar om marknadsföring som människor förstår, och vi gör det på vårt sätt.
Jag förstår.
Jag tänker att jag samtidigt som vi snackar, ska alla bolaga och se hur många det finns som heter Growth Digital.
Det måste vara det mest standardiserade namnet.
Vi hade liksom omrustning när vi röstade fram namnet Republiken som Byrån heter, då hade vi generiska namn och röstar ibland.
Vi var väldigt klara att vi inte gick den vägen och försökte efterlikna en marknadsledare som till exempel Precis Digital.
Fyller det övrigt någon funktion?
Alltså, är det såhär, ja, vi står för de romerska värderingarna av, eller är det bara en plojgrej?
Nej men det är ju tacksamt att bygga varumärke kring.
Den stora funktionen som det fyller för oss affärsmässigt är att det är lättare att komma ihåg oss.
Och det har vi nytta av när vi blir rekommenderade eller folk ska tänka på att nu ska köpa marknadsförandetjänster.
Det är det så, det går att bygga mycket kul kring det.
Ni har döpt era paket till, jag är lite osäker på om jag säger rätt, men typ Novice och Dominus och är beroende på storlek och liknande.
Får du någonsin kritik från kunder som är såhär, kan du inte bara döpa det till liten, medium och stor, varför måste ni krångla till det här?
Men de som inte gillar det hör inte av sig, så de slipper att prata med.
Men det fina var när vi släppte de paketerna, man var själv skeptisk om att säga det här för plåget.
Men det roliga var att veckan efter hade vi ett kundmöte där en kund sa att jag är intresserad av Dominus paketet, och jag trodde att han skämtade då, jag tänkte att det kan inte vara på allvar.
Men det är någonting med att paketera tjänster är viktigt, och sen sätta ett namn på det som är i linje med vilka vi är.
Sen är det inte så att alla gillar det, det kan jag absolut inte säga att alla gör, om det inte faller så är det.
Det låter nästan lite sexuellt.
Du behöver inte besvara det men...
Någon måste ju ha hamnat på sidan och har misstag nån gång.
I alla fall, kan du berätta lite kort om det själv innan vi går in på bolaget?
Vem är Pontus?
Jag är en marknadsförare bosatt i Göteborg.
Jag är en enkel bonde från Kalmar från början.
Flyttade hit i Göteborg för att plugga på handels för många år sedan.
Driver Marknadsföreningsbyrån Republiken.
Vi startade för fem år sedan.
Alltid tyckte att det var kul med företagande.
Jag började sälja konstiga grejer när jag var liten.
Som många andra tror jag, som är liknande saker idag.
Jag började sälja tv-spel på Blocket och var så himla glad.
För jag lade av anställd, köpte in dem billigt och sen lade jag på några kronor.
Men jag hade inte räknat med frakten så jag gick i minus på liksom, min första sälja tv-spel business var kraftigt minus.
Men jag var ändå glad på något sätt.
Jag tyckte det var gott att sälja på något sätt.
Jag har ju kollat upp dig såklart och du drev ett bolag som var Kalmar Bastuflotte.
Ja.
Det måste ju vara typ den bästa affärsidéen genom alla tider.
Ja men det var extremt roligt.
Vi var 20, bodde i Kalmar och fick nys om att man kunde liksom ha en sån här flotte med bastuflottor och batunnar på.
Så vi hittade ett bolag i Norrland som sålde bastuflottor då, ett jävligt shady bolag i Norrland var de enda vi kunde få tag på.
Så de fraktade ner rätt stor tio gånger fyra meter flotte med bastuflottor och batunnar på som vi smällde upp i...
Vi la den centralt i Kalmar så man såg den alltid när man åkte in till stan.
Det lå nära en stor väg, man såg den, satte upp en stor skylt och man började hyra ut bastu och batunnar till fester, svensksor och annat skoj.
Det var så jävla kul.
Jag älskar det.
Det var väldigt enkelt att göra folk nöjda.
De var ju glada när de kom dit.
De har druckit några öl, och så var de där två timmar att basta och bada och baltunna.
Jättegoolig business på alla sätt faktiskt.
Men det gick inte att skala.
Det hade ju gått att köra fler städer och sådär, men det är lite svårt.
Kanske inte det bolaget man vill skala.
Nu driver du en marknadsföringsbyrå.
Jag tycker att det är som konsult typ.
Jag vet inte riktigt vad det betyder.
Vad gör ni?
Det som vi hjälper kunderna med är att ta fram en strategi, hur ska vi marknadsföra det här bolaget?
Vilka ska vi vara?
Vad ska vi säga?
Hur ska vi få folk att bli intresserade?
Sedan så gör vi ut marknadsföringen då i digitala kanaler.
Så mycket annonsering på Google, Meta, LinkedIn, bland annat.
Ni gör både själva paid-delen, och ni gör även strategin, och ni gör även varumärkesanalysen.
Är det så jag ska tolka det?
Ja men precis, exakt så.
Är det bra att vara så breda?
Det känns som allt fler bolag börjar bli bredare.
Förr kändes det som att man går dit och så gör de paid.
De gör SEO, de gör inlänkar.
Men det känns som att folk blir allt mer breda.
Är inte det lite krångligt att hålla koll på alla de här människorna och kompetenserna?
Jo men absolut, det är en hög ribba.
Men samtidigt blir det mer och mer resursautomatiserat att bara sitta och ge ut annonser eller bara sitta att göra ut en sak.
Och sen också i grunden är det något.
Desto fler bolag man träffar, så saknas det en grund och en strategi för hur vi ska marknadsföra oss.
Och då behöver man hjälpa till med det, annars spelar det andra ingen roll.
När du säger att vi saknas en grundläggande strategi för marknaden, vad menar du då?
Att man inte vet vem kunden är typ eller?
Ett exempel är att man bara sitter och skriver massa inlägg i sin blogg och uppdaterar saker utan att ha en grundtank i vad ska marknadsföraren göra för oss och så vidare.
Man ska sälja eller?
Nej.
Det ska man göra, det ska man absolut göra.
Om en kund kommer till er, vilka kunder är det som kommer in?
Vad är det de oftast inte fattar?
Eller vad är det de hittar er för?
En typ kund som jobbar med tandläkarkedja, gymmkedja och tandläkarkedjan som exempel, de kommer till oss för att de vill ha fler bokningar till sina tandläkare.
Så de kommer till oss och säger hej vi vill ha fler bokningar, det funkar inte just nu, kan ni hjälpa oss?
Och så kikar vi på det.
Och då är det ju ofta så att de vill ha hjälp med något kortsiktigt som är tryck en jäkla massa Google Ads, tryck in en jäkla massa nya kunder och det säger vi att det är en del av det, men vi behöver tänka lite större också och det adderar fler aktivitet i den mixen.
Så ofta är det att man går in och släcker ett problem på kortsikt och sen får jobba med dem på lång sikt och bygga upp något som är lite större.
Ja för det måste vara ganska olönsamt eller halver meningslöst, det får väl inte du säga, men jag kan väl säga det att jobba med kunder på projektbasis, det kan väl aldrig vara bra.
Precis, 80% av våra kunder är på månadsbasis och det är också för att om vi ska vara duktiga på strategi så måste man gå in rätt djupt på kunden och kundens affär och förstå vad är det de gör, hur funkar branschen osv.
Så för oss funkar det inte med projekt.
Sen är det vissa som är duktiga på det men då är det mer avskämt att då gör man kanske en grej, då kanske gör jag en uppsättning av ett CRM och så gör du det åter om och om igen.
Vad är ni duktiga på?
Vad är det folk väljer er för jämfört med?
För det finns ju ett par marknadsföringsbror i Sverige.
Vad är era grej?
Det vanligaste är att vi förstår deras affär.
Så både om man frågar kunder, men jag är mycket sällsamtalig, och så frågar man varför valde ni oss och inte de fyra andra bronar som pitchade.
Ja men ni verkar förstå vår affär.
Det är ett vanligt svar.
Och likadant när man pratar om kunder, om jag skriver kundcase och intervjuar våra kunder så är det de två viktigaste sakerna för många kunder är att man är proaktiv, att vi håller i stafettpinnen och leder arbetet och att vi förstår deras affär.
Det är de två starkaste grejerna som har återkommit.
Och vem är det som förstår affären?
Är det du som sitter i de här säljmötena och förstår folk?
Eller vem är er The Good Guy?
Minst projektledaren i alla fall.
Så minst projektledaren, men ofta projektgruppen behöver förstå det som man jobbar med.
Är det en grej då att ni...
Är det liksom uttalat inifrån att ni ska förstå kunden?
Lägger ni extra tid på kunden?
Eller är det bara att ni är mycket smartare och trevligare än alla andra?
Varför får ni den?
Har ni någon speciell bakgrund eller...
Eller är det bara...
De kunde nästan stanna kvar i de som får bäst koppling med er.
Give me the details.
Det är en superbra fråga.
Men jag tror de flesta här har jobbat med marknadsföring i tio plus år.
Och jag tror det handlar om att det är någonting som man växer in i.
Inget bra svar på den frågan.
Men det är...
Det finns ju ganska många marknadsföringsbyråer och ganska ofta är det rent kast, typ två polare som började sälja AdWords.
Och sen så växer det upp till någonting.
Ni är ändå en, förlåt till alla andra, men ni är ändå ett riktigt bolag.
Ni har ju funnits ett tag och ni är, om jag bara läser här, men ni är liksom 18 pers.
Det kräver ju en del kunder och man behöver ju gå runt på ganska många kunder för att ligga och rulla på den summan som krävs där.
Kan du ta mig genom er historia när ni gick från en person som satt och hehehehe knackade någon kårdsnutt åt Facebook till att ni liksom blev ett riktigt bolag.
Ja, äh men.
Och var gärna själv förhärligande nu.
Inget ödmjuk, jag märker att du svarar väldigt konkret och liksom tydligt här.
Skiter det och bara gå in på fan vad bra vi var där 2020 för att då gjorde vi, ge mig liksom en story här nu.
Äh men vi var.
No pressure.
Perfekt.
Äh men från början så var vi ju ett jävligt gott gäng.
Så vi är fem personer som grundade republiken.
Och det är liksom stommen.
En jäkligt god stommen från början.
Vi älskar att jobba tillsammans.
Jobba fortfarande tillsammans fem och ett halvt år senare.
Och det är liksom från det som vi har byggt.
Men det som vi är bra på är sälja och leverera.
Alltså ska man bygga större konsultbolag så behöver man vara duktig på på att sälja i början.
Det var vi duktiga på i början.
Och leverera projekten.
Vi har byggt upp till 20 miljoner omsättning på inkommande förfrågningar med hjälp av Roma-temat, med hjälp av att göra bra projekt och lagt värde i att marknadsföra oss själva.
Vi har lagt värde i att inte vara skomakans barn.
Om vi ska vara trovärdiga ut mot kunder så vill vi också vara trovärdiga i att marknadsföringen funkar för republiken.
Det vi har lagt heder i från början det tror jag har hjälpt oss.
Alla fall upp till där vi är nu.
Men det är människor, jag tror det har varit mycket hjärta.
Det vi har varit bra på är att bygga med hjärta.
Folk här tycker verkligen om att jobba tillsammans.
Vi har hållit ihop jävligt länge.
Vi har en fin bild härute där vi är tolv av oss i Tåga som togs för fyra år sedan och elva personer på den bilden jobbar här fortfarande idag.
Jag tror att det är lite ovanligt, inom marknadsföring som är en jävla kortsiktig bransch och det är huxflux och det är hej och hå.
Så en bra stomme, bra grund.
Har ni haft det här Tåga-temat sen start?
Ja, det har vi.
Jag tänker att ni, vi hittar på namnet Republiken för att ni satt på Ölrepubliken och drog en bärs eller någonting.
Och så blev det det men sen blev det bara Tåga.
Nej jag säger inte att ni var så, det skulle kunna ha så.
Men vad hände då, om ni är fem grundare och så skulle ni ta in den här första anställda.
Hur var det för person nummer ett att komma in där till, här har vi fem polare som är rätt weird och klär upp sig.
Vem var den första anställda personen, hur fick ni in den personen?
Ja, alltså nu så är det risk att jag blandar ihop namn här, för jag vet inte exakt vem som var nummer ett och två och så vidare.
Någon gång där är det de första tre.
I början då, Olof, den personen av oss som rekryterar, han är ju konstig liksom, han går ju på, han har ju gått i faktiskt tågar på anställningsintervjuer, sätter sig på en restaurang i tåg och alla gillar ju inte det, alltså såklart.
Vissa blir overkväma eller tänker vad fan är det här för osörjöst, men de som gillade har nog liksom passat bra in, vill vara med och göra någonting som är annorlunda, något som är kul.
Vilka karaktärsdrag är det ni letar efter hos folk?
Alltså det är ju så här, vi vill ha folk med stort hjärta och som är jävligt duktiga på marknadsföring.
Och sen så att man vill vara med på tåget och göra något annorlunda, dels för oss själva men också för våra kunder.
Jag är också jävligt dålig, jag har försökt vara med i början och rekrytera men jag är så naiv och glad, jag tänker att alla personer kommer att bli svinbra.
Så jag håller mig så långt ifrån rekrytering som möjligt, för jag säger nog ja till allt som är där man får någon slags connection.
Jag fattar, jag är lite likadan faktiskt.
Det är nästan bättre att lagret rekryterar själva till lagret och kontoret till kontoret och så går jag på deras rekombinationer.
Det brukar vara smidigt alltså.
Men när ni började växa här, för ni är ju fem grundare, hur får man ett flöde i kunder?
Det har ju ändå varit en ganska bra, stabil tillväxt.
Det är ju inte helt enkelt för att om ett konto försvinner så måste det ersättas.
Ni har ju en ganska svår affärsmodell kan jag tycka att man hela tiden behöver fylla på.
Och jag som beställare på andra sidan, nu är inte jag er kund men jag bara menar, jag som beställare får ju hundra andra förfrågningar varje vecka av andra byråer som vill jobba med en och det får ju era kunder också.
Så hur bibehåller man den leveransen?
Hur jobbar ni mot kund?
Hur ser ni till att öka på?
Att de ska tycka att det är intressant år efter år att jobba med er?
För det är en ganska kortsiktig bransch och alla kommer med nya löften hela tiden.
Det har ju varit speciella år att jobba med marknadsföring, det har varit krymta marknadsbudgetar, det har varit svårare och svårare att vinna nya kunder.
Det som funkar bra och det som kommer fortsätta att funka bra, det är de projekten där vi får sitta nära ledningsgruppen, nära vd, nära grundaren.
Vi har många av våra största uppdrag, de har ingen marknadschef, så då tar vi den rollen som marknadschef, vi bestämmer vad som ska göras och gör det.
Då blir vi mindre sårbara, kontra om det är en konsult som gör en väldigt avgränsad liten grej i ett marknadsteam.
Så receptet för att växa har varit återigen att vara duktiga och förstå affären, kunna gå in till en ledningsgrupp och berätta vad generera marknadsföringen för er, hur jobbar vi, och jobba mer på det sättet då.
Så långt ifrån resurser man kan komma.
Hur kritisk får man vara mot kunden som man jobbar med?
Kan man säga typ, det här är ju skit.
Ja, man får ju vara lite fint känslig, men det är ju superviktigt.
En av våra viktigaste roller och funktioner är ju att utmana.
Vi är ju hellre tjatiga och jobbiga, och till slut förlorar en kund än att göra något som vi inte tror på.
Där har det varit en balans också.
Särskilt lågkonjunktur och hur jobbig får man vara.
Men jobbig, vårt perspektiv är utifrån, och det är ofta enklare för oss att säga hur fattas den här marknadsföringen faktiskt ska vara för er kunder, vad tycker jag kunder faktiskt är.
Ibland kan det vara om man pratar med folk som är väldigt stolta och bara har varit inneifrån perspektivet, men fan vårt bolag är gymt, alla som jobbar älskar det.
Ja men er kunder tycker inte det är nice.
Och då måste vi säga det.
Och det är också rätt tacksamt att vara utifrån då, för vi sitter ju inte liksom ut hos kunder och så, utan vi går ju mycket på vad säger kundens kund när vi pratar med er kunder, vad säger de faktiskt om det.
Och den diffen är ofta stor om man ska vara ärlig.
Vad man bolaget tror om en själva och vad deras kunder tror, det är ofta stort skillnad.
Är det det som är företagens största problem, att de inte vet vad kunder egentligen tycker?
Är det det vi gör mest fel?
Företagens största problem är att man utgår helt ifrån sig själv.
Man tänker inifrån och ut, man tänker mer vad vill vi göra, vad vill vi sälja snarare än vad vill kunder köpa.
Det är så superbasic, men internt fokus.
Eftersom vi pratar mycket med kundernas kunder, så får vi ett perspektiv som är, det är rätt saxamt att vi förmedlar men så här säger de.
Vi lägger ingen värdering av skit i det.
Men det är så här marknaden ser på er.
Det är ganska intressant.
Jag tror aldrig jag har gjort någon sådan undersökning.
Det kanske man borde göra, se vad folk tycker.
Men du har säkert pratat mycket med era kunder och har väldigt bra koll på vad som funkar, varför gillar man er, vad är det som gör att ni ibland bristar och så vidare.
Får man ju mycket från säljselmålet.
Du får vara kritisk här.
Du kan bara säga, fan du har ingen koll alls på detta.
Det är lugnt.
Jag vet inte vad trevlig är.
Okej, vad är det mer företag gör fel?
Man utgår från sig själv vad man vill sälja snarare än vad folk faktiskt vill köpa och vad de tycker.
Är det något mer folk, du kommer in i ett nytt bolag och säger, fan det här brukar vara skit.
Det som brukar vara skit är att bolag är så extremt kortsiktiga.
Det är så extremt kortsiktig tänk i att tryckkommitteringar på Google.
Kortsikt, kortsikt, kortsikt.
Man lägger liksom all budget i kortsiktig kommitteringsbacket om man säger så, och fokar alldeles för lite på lång sikt.
Man fokar väldigt mycket på de som är i marknaden och köper produkter nu.
Om man tar för er till exempel att man ska köpa gymprodukter till sitt hem, eller ska bygga ett hemmagym.
Om ni bara lägger alla pengar, alla pengar på Google Ads, år efter år, år efter år, år efter år, och inte gör någonting annat för att bygga kärnedom, bygga varumärke, då kommer det att leda till dåligt resultat på sikt.
Så bolaget är alldeles för kortsiktiga i sin marknadsföring.
Det är ett stort problem.
Men jag tycker alltid att det där är flummigt när folk säger att man ska bygga varumärke.
Vadå ska jag gå ut och göra någon film om att vi klappar hundar?
Vad fan är varumärkesidan då?
Det är väldigt enkelt egentligen.
Om du börjar i slutet istället, du vill att fler folk ska köpa gym av dig, det är det som du vill uppnå.
Då har du två olika grupper.
Den ena gruppen är de som aktivt letar efter gym.
De googlar eller söker på Youtube.
Där är ni duktiga, där kan man se ditt bolag, köpa er produkter.
Sen har du de andra som inte, till exempel jag.
Jag letar inte aktigt nu efter att köpa gymprodukter, men jag kanske köper ett hemmagym när vi köper ett större hus.
Så när jag köper en villa om fyra år och ska bygga ett gym i min källare, då kommer jag tänka på Joel, då kommer jag tänka på gymkompaniet, då finns det min skalla redan innan jag börjar googla gym.
Det är det du vill göra när du bygger ett varumärke, du vill finnas i huvudet innan man aktivt söker.
Så om man tänker på det så istället så är det ganska enkelt.
Du gör det bra på LinkedIn, du gör det bra med podd, du är bra på att bygga ett varumärke.
Men är det inte lite onödigt att lägga för att 99% av de man träffar med den här marknadsföringen kommer inte att handla gym någon gång, så är det inte lite bara såhär, ja vad kul att vi har en varumärkeskännedom på 15%, vem fan bryr sig om det, jag bryr mig bara om den där sista procenten.
Om du vill tjäna pengar så ska du bry dig om det, för det är 5% i snitt som är liksom, 5% på en marknad i snitt som är in the market får köpa din produkt, man letar aktivt sätt att köpa ett hemma gym nu för att generalisera.
De andra 95% är mycket billigare att nå om man säger så.
Alla bolag slåss om de 5% som är in the market, det är därför det blir dyrare med Google-annonsering, det är därför annonspriserna går upp år efter år.
Så om du bara fortsätter lägga pengar där i sikt, då kommer du inte på lång sikt bygga ett riktigt stort och bra bolag.
Så du behöver vara bra på att bygga varumärken för att bygga ett riktigt fint bolag.
Jag köper det, det var en jävla bra förklaring för jag vet.
Hur hittar man den sweet spoten, för att speciellt nu har vi varit i lågkonjunktur och det är ganska, vi kanske fortfarande är, men liksom det har varit ganska svårt att försvara att allokera pengar till någonting som inte ger resultat idag, för att ganska många är på någon sorts bristningsgräns.
Hur bestämmer man vad man får allokera till om tre år eller att bygga någon sorts framtida sälj?
Nej men precis, det finns en sådan kurva, alltså när man delar upp hur mycket budget lägger vi på kortsikt och långsikt och det bästa sättet är att kolla på men hur utvecklar sig kacken, hur utvecklar sig kostnaden på en ny kund på den här högen vi har med kortsikt?
Och när man känner, det finns ju i början, när du startar ett bolag, E-handel till exempel, då kommer du kunna trycka mycket i kortsikt och få mycket nya kunder, men när du ser att den kostnaden blir högre och högre och högre, det är liksom ett av tecknen på att vi behöver göra mer på varumärkesidan, mer på långsikt.
Okej, fair enough, jag köper det.
Kan det inte bara vara att marknaden är rätt metta då?
Eller dör aldrig kunderna ut?
Kan man...
Ja men fan, jag gillar det.
Fan vad bra jävla förklaringar.
Ja, vad kul.
Det är ändå svårt att avgöra hur mycket man ska allokera till framtida.
Hur flummigt får framtida säljvara, alltså att bygga varumärke, finns det någon skala, jag tycker ofta att man generaliserar så säger man så, ja man ska lägga 40% på kortsiktigt och 60% på långsiktigt om man verkligen vill bygga varumärke.
Ja, absolut.
De går ju ganska mycket in i varandra, det är ganska mycket gråzon.
Hur flummi får man vara i sitt varumärkesbyggande i att det inte drar in pengar just nu.
Hur brukar ni prata när ni rekommenderar kunder?
Enklast är att börja med Outcom, du vill sälja mer.
För att sälja mer så behöver du finnas i skallen redan innan man aktivt söker efter er produkt eller tjänst.
För att finnas i skallen så behöver du bygga varumärker och påminna om att ditt bolag finns.
Så försöker du ta ner det så mycket och så enkelt som möjligt.
Och komma bortifrån, för det behöver inte vara flummigt och svårt.
Det behöver inte vara en stor brandfilm, det behöver inte vara så häftigt och det behöver inte vara så flashigt.
Utan det handlar om att bara enkelt finnas i skallen.
IKEA finns i din skalle när du flyttar hemifrån och ska inredda din första studentlyra.
Då finns IKEA i din skalle.
De är duktiga på varumärker, de associeras med att köpa möbler billigt.
Du behöver inte googla dig fram till det.
Därför har de ett tryggt varumärke.
IKEA påminner dig i din skalle med sådana här blå och gula färger.
IKEA finns i många huvudar.
De har ett starkt varumärke förknippade med situationer som ofta uppstår.
De blir tänkta på redan innan köpsituationen.
Man behöver inte googla.
IKEA behöver inte slåss om och synas på billiga kontorsmöbler eller billig säng.
De spelar en annan ballgame.
Vill man bli riktigt så behöver man spela det på sikt.
Man börjar på kort sikt.
Det är jättebra att spela det i början när man är i ett litet bolag.
Självklart pengarna ska in.
Men ska man bli riktigt stor och bygga ett riktigt bra bolag så behöver man ha ett starkt varumärke på sikt.
De är ju fantastiskt duktiga på att bygga varumärket kring en situation.
Nu ska jag flytta hemifrån.
Då tänker man på IKEA.
Om man tänker på en soffa tänker man säkert också på IKEA.
Men då tänker man också på Mio.
Jag kan inte så jävla många möbelföretag så jag kan inte säga.
Men att flytta hemifrån är ju förknippat med IKEA.
Eller om barnen ska bygga ett större rum och köpa in en säng, då tänker man på IKEA.
De är nästan situationsanpassade, snarare än produktanpassade.
Och det är så man ska jobba med varumärke.
Vilka situationer vill du bli förknippad med ditt bolag?
När jag tänker på hemmagym, då ska jag tänka på gym-kompaniet.
Det är så man bygger varumärke.
Så du tar en association, ser till att äga den, sen tar du en till, en till, en till, en till.
Så de bolagen som blir mest associerade och poppar först i skallen på många, alltså de riktigt stora bolagen har ju hundratals olika associationer, då blir man köpt många gånger, har ett bra varumärke.
Ja, jag köper det.
Du innan detta så snackade vi litegrann om 4P, som är någon sorts koncept eller ledstjärna eller sätt att tänka.
Det är en flumig fråga, kan du förklara lite om det?
Nämen 4P är en modell inom marknadsföring som intervjueras 1960, och den lever än idag.
Om man tar lite bakgrund så är det såhär, bolag fokuserar alldeles för mycket på promotion, påverkan, ett av de 4P-erna.
Bolag är liksom ösa in pengar i marknadsföring, ösa in pengar i annonser, men de är inte alltid så duktiga på att jobba med produkt, pris och plats.
Så produkten är en superviktig del i marknadsföringen.
Marknadsföringen ska informera produkten.
Marknadsföring får jättemycket feedback på marknaden.
Det ska man se till att det kommer in i produktteamet, oavsett om det är produkt eller tjänster man bygger.
Så marknadsföring ska vara med och bygga och styra vilka produkter och tjänster man säljer.
Det har gått förlorat i marknadsföringen idag.
Marknadsföringen idag är isolerad till att bara handla om promotion för många bolag.
Ditt marknadsteam jobbar bara med annonseringen, så de får inte sitta med och planera vilka produkter eller tjänster ni ska bygga.
Det är fel och det leder också till dåligt resultat.
När man isolerar marknadsföringen till bara promotion av de fyra penade.
Varför hamnar vi där?
Det måste ju finnas en fördel med det eftersom vi har rört också åt det hållet.
Varför har man gjort så då?
Eller så är det en vagga att vi kommer att röra oss tillbaka åt det andra hållet snart igen.
Jag tror att det hör ihop med det kortsiktiga och mätbara.
Det är väldigt enkelt som marknadsföring i början att kolla.
Kolla vad duktiga, kolla vilka bra resultat jag ska ha på genom Google Ads.
Och till slut så sitter man bara och gör mer och mer och mer av det.
Men i slutändan så är det så här, det är enbart att bara sitta och jobba med promotion delen av marknadsföring.
Det kommer inte räcka.
Du behöver liksom fortsätta utveckla din produkt.
Vad säger kunden om produkten?
Fortsätta utveckla dina tjänster.
Som duktig marknadsförare är duktig på alla de fyra P-erna.
Duktig på produkt, pris, plats och promotion.
Pris är också en sådan sak.
Hur ofta pratar du pris med en marknadsförare eller pratar pris inom marknadsförening?
Det är superviktigt.
De flesta bolag sätter sitt pris helt fel.
Man sätter sitt pris på vad det kostar att tillverka och lägga en liten avans på den.
Eller så sätter man sitt pris på att kolla på konkurrenterna och så lägger man sig i mitten.
Det bästa sättet att sätta pris är att jobba med upplevt värde.
Man kan sätta mycket högre pris om man jobbar efter helt andra tankebanor och modeller.
Men det är också en sån grej.
Hur ofta har du marknadsförare varit duktiga på att resonera kring hur du ska priset den här produkten?
Det är en jätteviktig del av marknadsföring och väldigt underutnyttjat.
Så därför är den gamla, heredliga 4P-modellen superviktig marknadsföring och superviktig att ha med sig när man ska sälja mycket.
När du säger plats hur vi ska, vad är det vi gör fel där då?
Jag fattar till exempel att jag ska ha en bra e-handel, det ska vara smidigt för kunden, men hur menar du att marknadsföring ska ha en påverkan på det?
Vad är det för koppling som inte finns idag?
Som ett exempel så skulle en marknadsförare till dig kunna säga att du ska ha en flagship store på fysisk plats, därför att det skulle kunna vara ett exempel på hur en marknadsförare informerar det beslutet, bara som ett exempel.
Men det som är viktigt med plats idag är att platsen, oavsett om man säljer fysiskt eller digitalt, att det är extremt enkelt att köpa av dig, vilket många i alla är superduktiga på idag.
När du pratar om det såhär så är det nästan som att marknadsföring ska ha någon sorts ydercentral roll i hela verksamheten och sitta och bara ha koll på allting.
Är detta bara ditt sätt att sälja in er viktighet?
Alltså marknadsföringen ska ha en supercentral roll i bolaget.
En duktig marknadschef ska sitta i ledningsgruppen.
Ett marknadsteam som har höga mål om att pusha tillväxt och resultat, de ska ha mycket att säga till om produkten, om priset.
Annars kommer man inte att skapa det resultatet som riktigt ambitiösa bolag vill.
Det finns ju olika sätt att se på det men det är min fasta övertygelse.
Det känns också lite enkelt.
Det låter som att dialogen går från marknadsföringen till produkten och priset och platsen.
Hur sker dialogen åt andra hållet?
Kan produktfolket ha en åsikt mot marknadsföringen eller är det bara stanna och göra en grej eller blir det bara flummigt?
Nej men det är klart att det är samverkan med...
Du behöver inte vara schysst i detta.
Så som det ska vara får du säga.
Så som det är är det att marknadsföre har bäst förståelse för de har bäst förståelse för kunderna.
Så det är de som ska bestämma allt på hela ditt bolag.
Hahaha, jag tror att det kommer att vara, det kommer att vara så intro segmentet i...
Jag älskar det.
Nej men då så, fuck it.
Då abdikerar jag här och så låter jag de som sköter marknadsföringen ta över.
Jag ska dock säga att jag håller med i ganska mycket.
Vi har till exempel, bara för att förstärka det på något sätt.
Vi har låtit de som handlar om våra marknadsföring, de har direkt kanal till it-utveckling och de har direkt kanal till de som sitter med SEO och hemsida och styr hur hemsidan ser ut.
De har ju ganska mycket frågor om vilka produkter kommer in, hur ska de här göras och vad får ni in mycket av eller lite, vilka marginaler finns i de här.
Så jag håller med i allt detta, jag tror att man underskattar det ganska mycket, hur viktig den rollen är och hur mycket de ska få.
Och då är det dessutom en extern byrå, det är inte vi själva men ändå låter vi de få ganska mycket att säga till dem.
Jag håller absolut med.
Vad är det man är sämst på att göra här?
Är det att vi inte vågar släppa kontrollen eller är det att vi tror att vi vet bättre i marknadsföringsbyråer?
Vad är det kunden gör dåligt här ofta?
Det som kunden gör dåligt många gånger är att man bygger en jävla massa produkter som ingen vill ha.
Man tar fram produkter och tjänster som vårt bolag kan bygga där.
Det är jättehäftig teknik eller vi kan tillverka det här, det är jättebra.
Men man har ingen lyhörighet, är det det här marknaden behöver?
Vill folk ha det, löser det verkliga problem?
Så det är särskilt nu, det bara öser ut nya digitala verktyg och tjänster.
Mycket byggs för att det är coolt och man kan bygga det.
Man borster bara i andre änden.
Vad är det för problem som finns?
Det låter så basic, men det är jättemånga bolag som startas för att det går att gå och starta det, det går att bygga det.
Har du några exempel på, jag vet inte om du får dela det, men har du några exempel på hur ni har jobbat med någon kund där det verkligen har funkat bra i symbios, eller där du har gett bra resultat, eller där du kan förklara att det här var ett bra upplägg?
Har du något du får eller kan dela med dig om?
Vad tänker du på specifikt overall, eller något specifikt med produkt, eller vad tänker du på då?
Vilket som egentligen, bara något case som du känner.
Fan det här är jag stolt över.
Jag tycker ofta att det blir så jävla flummigt när man pratar med marknadsföringsbyråer, så är det såhär, vi ska jobba med varumärke, och vi ska göra det här.
Absolut kan ni dela med er om någonting?
Nej det får vi inte göra.
För man vill ju inte säga vad man har gjort.
Och jag har full respekt för om du inte vill dela med dig.
Jag bara menar att det hade varit kul att få någon.
Ja men precis, jobba med ett roligt uppdrag nu, där vi bygger en vårdkedja, som har både fysisk och digitala mottagningar.
Och där så har vi gått ifrån, de fanns inte för tre år sedan.
Så från att vara ingenting till att omsätta hundra miljoner och ha ett varumärke som faktiskt folk tycker om, hittar, besöker och köper av.
Så det är en häftig resa, sen är det svårt att gå in i detalj.
Men säg då den här vårdkedjan, då gissar jag att de behöver bygga någon sorts trustworthiness eller pålitlighet eller trygghet mot kunden.
Men är det så man börjar analysen av det varumärket?
Eller hur sätter man igång analysen av vad man ska jobba med?
I det fallet så handlar det om att, återigen vad är det stora problemet?
Varför ska den här vårdkedjan finnas över huvud taget?
Det finns en jävla massa redan.
Varför ska den här finnas?
Var är platsen på marknaden?
I det här fallet så är det att vård för kvinnor är eftersatt.
Man får inte den uppmärksamhet och kärlek den behöver.
Där utvecklar vi produkt och tjänster som löser det problemet.
Som ger bra vård för kvinnor och bygger ett varumärke kring det.
Är det alltid den frågan man börjar med?
Varför ska de här finnas?
Det är en bra fråga att ställa, absolut.
Ibland kan jag bara känna att de flesta bolag är ju inte så jävla viktiga.
Det ska finnas en frisör till, det finns ju tio stycken.
Det ska finnas någon som säljer gym rent krass, det finns ju andra som säljer gym.
Men det behöver inte vara så jävla kryssat.
Svaret kan vara så här att vi är en frisör som klipper väldigt fina frillor och när man går härifrån så har man en riktigt god känsla i magen.
Det är liksom ett existensberättigande bland tusentals andra frisörer.
Så det behöver inte vara heligt.
Jag tror att många bolag har gått bort sig i att okej vi måste ha ett syfte som räddar världen.
Därför blir vi ängsliga och så vågar vi inte säga vårt egentliga syfte.
Det egentliga syftet är superviktigt och det kan vara att göra någonting lite bättre, göra folk lite gladare.
Det är också ett syfte nog så gott.
Men man måste vara ärlig kring det och bygga kring det.
Nu använder jag oss själva som exempel väldigt mycket och det är lite tråkigt för någon säkert.
Men det är kul för mig.
Du sa här förut att nu byggde jag lite varumärke på LinkedIn till exempel eller via den här podden.
Det har ju typ ingen koppling alls till min verksamhet.
Det är väldigt svårt att komma på det sättet att bygga varumärke.
Nu har det ju gått bra liksom.
Jag får jättemycket pr och läsare och kunder också för den delen som kommer in.
Hur fan ska man, behöver inte ens varumärkesbyggande vara mot ens riktiga kärnverksamhet?
Fan vad flummigt och stort det blir eller?
Precis, alltså du gör ju någonting som gör att du på sikt kommer få fler och fler som lyssnar på dig, fler och fler som hör på dig och folk är inte dumma i huvudet.
Alla som du är i kontakt med, associerar dig med ditt bolag.
Vad säljer ni för produkter?
Så du bygger där, den kopplingen just nu är inte så stark, men du kommer få mer och mer utrymme, kommer få fler och fler som lyssnar på din podd, synas i fler och fler artiklar och så vidare.
Så du bygger ditt personliga varumärke först riktigt starkt och sen kan man bygga kopplingen starkare längre fram i olika sammanhang.
Brukar ni rekommendera att man gör det personberoende, detta är en personberoende marknadsföring som jag håller på med, om vi ska kalla det.
Är det bra eller negativt?
Det är hundra procent bra.
Vi jobbar med att bygga talespersoner på LinkedIn som det så fint heter.
I grund och botten så är det så att vi människor gillar ansikten och människor.
Det är enklare att bygga en loggård i början, särskilt om man är i ett litet bolag.
Sen är det enklare att alla som bygger ett bolag kan berätta hur är den här resan för mig?
Det är att dokumentera, det kan alla göra.
Oavsett om man tycker det är svårt eller har lite tid.
Dokumentera, hur ser resan ut?
Det är du duktig på, och det är många som lyssnar.
Då kan man ha olika vinklar in på det och känna igen sig av problem.
Så bra tips är, är det svårt och luddigt att bygga varumärker?
Bygger du ett bolag, dokumentera din resa.
Det är ett bra sätt att bygga ditt varumärke på.
Hur rädd ska man vara för att stöta bort kunder?
Det är aktuellt för er också, ni som vi nämnde här i början, ni har ju en egen stil.
Ni kommer ju stötta bort en viss kundgrupp.
Ska man bara skita i det eller inte tänka på det?
Det är bra.
En av de viktigaste principen inom marknadsföring för att bli köpt mycket är liking, alltså att man tycker om en.
För att bli omtyckt så kommer du att ha i andra händer folk som inte tycker om dig.
Folk som tycker du är löjlig eller fel, eller din produkt är inte för mig, fel priset och så vidare.
Så du måste liksom vara med dig själv.
Låt ditt bolag vara med som ditt bolag är.
Om du bygger dig själv som personligt varumärke, var med dig själv.
Du ska inte bli omtyckt av alla.
Det är liksom inte slutmålet.
Och hur långt kan vi ha?
Just nu pågår ju den här power-kampanjen som folk skriver om på LinkedIn överallt.
Där de typ, jag tror att det är så här, jag är inte så insatt i sånt här, men jag tror att det är att om man blir gravid inom några månader efter att man har köpt oss om så får man pengar tillbaka.
Det är något åt det hållet i alla fall.
Den är inte jätteomtyckt av en del människor eller ganska många.
Är det mer en plojgrej eller bygger det varumärke eller är det bra att synas bara för att synas?
De försöker bygga varumärke gör det riktigt dåligt.
Det finns en myt så att alla...
Det finns en myt inom marknadsföring som säger att all uppmärksamhet är bra uppmärksamhet.
Nej!
Om en stor PR-grej leder till att det byggs fler negativa associationer till ditt bolag, det är negativt fler, det kommer inte att handla av dig för att folk hatar dig.
När fler personer tycker illa om ditt varumärke kommer det inte att vara bra för dig.
Så hade det varit så enkelt som att all uppmärksamhet är bra uppmärksamhet, då har du bakom dig att göra en massa konstiga uttalar, nu har det varit kontroversiell hela tiden, det är inte alls det det handlar om.
Det är många som försöker gömma sig bakom det, men det är liksom inte ett bra spel att spela.
Okej, så man får vara lite udda, men man får vara udda med besinning.
Man får vara sig själv.
Du får använda din skalle när du ska vara udda.
Det kan ju vara bra liksom.
Ja, jag köper det.
Kan vi också göra någon sorts, det är ju en djungel därute med marknadsfiroföringsbyråer och nu har jag ju e-handlare och det finns ju många e-handlare som lyssnar på denna och alla har ju haft en eller två eller tre byråer som är skit och som har typ halvblåstom.
Hur vet man, när man tar kontakt med en byrå, hur vet man att det är en bra byrå?
Vad är det vi ska titta efter?
Ja men det ni ska titta efter i början är ju att träffa teamet som ni ska jobba med.
För ofta så slänger man fram en jätteduktig säljare och sen är det några helt andra personer som sitter, kanske mer juniorer som sitter och ska utföra det.
Så träffa projektgruppen tidigt, det är de ni behöver få förtroende för, det är de som ska jobba med ditt bolag.
Så träffa projektgruppen, be om relevanta case, har ni löst liknande utmaningar, vi står inför de här utmaningarna, känner vi igen oss i de case som presenteras.
Så träffa teamet, bra case och sen en jävla god känsla för att jobba tillsammans.
Jag tror också på, det låter så jävla clichet, men hitta folk som verkligen tycker det är kul att jobba med.
Det kommer kännas när marknadsföraren tycker det är riktigt kul att jobba med ditt bolag.
Men att säga att man inte är så, man omsätter tre miljoner och man har kämpat under några år och börjat komma igång och sälja lite, då är man inte så kaxig så går man till en marknadsförarensbyrå och så säger man att man vill träffa teamet, jag vill ha den här.
Ganska många marknadsförarensbyrå kommer inte att säga absolut vi avsätter åtta start-up-möten för dig som vi kommer att få in 7000 i månaden för.
Den är superviktig.
Omsätter du tre miljoner ska du inte gå till en stor byrå på det sättet för du kommer ofta att inte bli prioriterad.
Utan gå till någon, en duktig frilansare till exempel eller en mindre byrå.
Så det är också en viktig grej att matcha på något sätt.
Byrån var inte bygons absolut minsta kund.
Det är väldigt sällan bra.
Utan hitta någon byrå eller frilansare som är på din nivå någonstans i vad du är med ditt bolag och vad du omsätter.
Okej, vi tar en längre då.
Säg att du är den här tre miljoner och så har den här frilansaren jobbat upp dig till tio, elva miljoner.
När är det dags att byta?
När känner man att det är dags att ta nästa steg?
För det blir ganska lätt att man bara går ut och letar hela tiden efter jag ska ha en ny plattform, jag ska ha en ny marknadsvärde, jag ska ha en ny skänkdata, det blir lätt att man letar för mycket.
När vet man när det är dags att gå vidare?
När det inte funkar längre.
Men det är också så, om jag hade omsatt tre miljoner idag med min e-handel och letat efter konsulter som jag kan ha lite mer på lång sikt och bygga någonting med tillsammans.
Som du säger, det tar en jävla massa tid och energi och bara byta, leta nytt, source.
Så hitta folk du vill jobba med länge i alla fall som ambition.
Nej, jag gillar det.
Fan, jävla bra insikter det här.
Jag hoppas alla fick med sig det.
Jag är jättenöjd.
Är det något som du tänker på Pontus som du vill lägga till, som du känner att vi saknar?
Nej men otroligt kul.
Jag tycker att alla borde liksom köra all in på var med er själva i ett bolag och var mer romare.
Börja din tåga, stoltare och mer ofta.
Är det att folk är rädda för att vara sig själva eller är det bara att man inte har personlighet?
Ja du, det är en jävla bra fråga.
Nej men det är ju läskigt alltså.
Man känner sig betygsatt och alla kommer inte att gilla det här.
Skit i det, var er själva.
Var lite mer av er själva istället.
Så länge ni inte går hela vägen.
Inte full blown power, men stanna 60 procent därifrån.
Stanna precis steget innan full power, då kommer det bli skit.
Jättebra.
Stort tack för att du var med på den.
Stort tack.
Om ni bara lägger alla pengar, alla pengar på Google Ads år efter år, år efter år, år efter år och inte gör någonting annat för att bygga kännedom, bygga varumärke då kommer det att leda till dåligt resultat på sikt.